it's time for the fastest first stop
have a look on the sa my gosh
we're going against the wind the wind's
120 knots the west
we're about to get our hands on the on a
huge government report on ufos u.s
intelligence reportedly found no
evidence that these objects are alien
spacecraft
but they're they have they've they have
not ruled out the possibility
kennedy what do you think they're still
lying to us no i don't i don't buy that
company line
at all uh there's something really weird
going on china wishes they have this
kind of technology
and there are even theories that the
united states didn't fact down
alien spacecraft in the 1950s reverse
engineered what they could
and have some hybrid experiments that
they keep under wraps
in government programs with no
accountability
so jesse are they for mars are they from
venus i don't know but we haven't
found one yet and that's the point once
we get the little green guy
in our grass that's when we're playing
with fire right so
how do you meet the guy i mean do you
poke him do you shake his hand if you
shake his hand
that could be offensive in another
galaxy
they eat your hand and then you know eat
the alien no
no no no no that's the first thing you
guys that's like shots fired then you
have the whole
alien world descending upon jesse we
already eat earthlings
we eat cows we eat
lamb if we're gonna eat earthlings we
should eat the aliens
instead of our own brothers and sisters
on this planet are you an alien is that
what you're saying
possibly we we could be i could be a
simulation
sent down from another planet i'm going
to probe you so she'll find out
so shannon that brings up a good point i
mean what if the aliens are living here
on earth already
here's my theory first of all i love how
they say they also deny it's part of any
secret government operation well okay
it's secret they're not gonna tell us so
of course right kennedy uh also i think
that they've come to visit
because we have these crafts here they
might be living among us but what i
think is they took one look and they're
like nope we're out
earth is too messed up when you guys get
everything straightened out we'll come
back
wait a ufo doesn't mean anything it just
means
unidentified flying object birds are
ufos
if you don't know that they're birds
those are probably just birds
this story reminds me of the sideshow
when you
used to go to the carnival and they tell
you ooh you got the bearded lady you got
the lizardman
and you go in there and it's just some
dude in a costume this is
all baloney that means late at night you
could be a ufo i
i prefer the british band ufo up up next
monopoly seems like a fun and
interesting board game but it's the
source of a lot of family fighting
one in five people have actually banned
it because it causes problems at game
night
including leading to physical fights
jesse most last time you fought over
monopoly
well last weekend i was playing monopoly
with the twins and
sophia bought all of the railroads all
four of them i think that's a garbage
strategy
it's a great strategy but ellie and i
kept landing on the railroads and every
time you land on one if you own four
that's 200 bucks so she starts stacking
up a bunch of cash
and then she starts putting down all of
these houses and hotels
she bankrupts me so what do i do i'm an
adult so i flip the board and store him
out of the room
that's right trumpian of you that's hey
shannon how about you um i do not like
to play games because i'm super
competitive and i love
my peoples my family my friends so it's
best if i don't play
wow you have a problem i do i really do
that's my favorite little shannon breeze
right
evil [ __ ] i called it
my theory is the mark of a bad game and
monopoly is a bad game
is you can't play two out of three or
three out of five it's too long so when
you're losing
it's kind of a life sentence that night
you're stuck losing so that's why you
get really pissed off
i am a candyland fan because i love
beating the crap out of those kids they
just they don't know
what hit them all over them like at
steam
i step on them like rap you're not
allowed around kids greg that's not what
the judge said
it was a misunderstanding all right so
kennedy so he he he
he's not a big fan he likes he plays
candyland with the children
in his van i'm assuming you play
monopoly like an adult
uh i do like i tried to play uh
electronic monopoly the other day and it
was very confusing i like the board i'm
a tactile person and what's your what's
your what's your favorite property to
buy what's your group of property
place park places come on man classy
girl but i do
there's a game i like called apples to
apples that you can play with any age
and it's really fun you're given like
five objects and then there's a card
that's like what's something that's
really gross
and you have like a beach ball a peanut
butter and jelly sandwich
teddy bears you're like i don't know so
you have to make the case for why your
thing is gross isn't that a drinking
game kennedy what's that is that's a
drinking game i thought every game is a
drinking game it can be
maybe that's why you flip the board of
monopoly jesse that's right i had a few
too many with my daughters
no richard no